[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur le plateau d'
interdit d'interdire face aux variants
delta le vario indien qui ne représente
aujourd'hui que 4 à 6 % des cas en
france mais qui est encore plus
contagieux que le vario ralph haye
pourrait se multiplier pendant l'été
devenir majoritaire à l'automne il faut
vacciner toujours plus de gens parlent
de 95% de la population française pour
atteindre l'immunité collective
le problème c'est qu'il reste une partie
de la population qui elle refuse de se
faire vacciner
y compris parmi les soignants olivier
ferrand le ministre de la santé a même
parlé de rendre le vaccin obligatoire
pour le personnel de peur le personnel
soignant des ehpad en particulier en
attendant on a ouvert la vaccination aux
adolescents entre 12 et 18 ans mais là
aussi tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
arguant qu'à cet âge les risques
l'emportent sur les bénéfices et l'on
parle de vaccinations altruistes pas
seulement de vaccination égoïste à leur
penchant pour en débattre
nous avons invité aurélie haroche vous
êtes rédactrice en chef de jim point fr
le journal international de médecine
leader de l'information médicale
francophone
alors imaginons que je sois un
adolescent de 12 13 ou 14 ans j'ai envie
de faire vacciner en même temps j'hésite
je viens vous voir je me demande
qu'est-ce que vous conseiller d'aller me
faire vacciner ou pas assez difficile
c'est une question difficile je pense
que un adolescent on peut lui dire bon
voilà est-ce que toi l'épidémie ça te
pose des problèmes est ce que tu as
souffert de l'épidémie il va
probablement répondu oui parce qu'il a
moins pu voir ses copains il a moins pu
aller à l'école
donc ça c'est une bonne raison de se
faire vacciner après il faut quand même
lui faire comprendre que ce n'est pas
sûr à 100% c'est pas parce qu'il va se
faire vacciner que les écoles ne vont
pas peut être fermé parce que peut-être
qu'il y aura un variant ou peut-être
fera pas assez de personnes vaccinées il
faut qu'ils arrivent quand même à
comprendre il faut pas que ils aient
l'impression en octobre six tours ferme
qu'on lui a menti quand il faut qu'il
arrive à comprendre que c'est pas sûr
que c'est un pari
christian bréchot vous êtes virologues
professeur à l'university of south
florida président de global virus
network ancien directeur général de
l'inserm de l'institut mérieux et même
de l'institut pasteur même cas
l'adolescent vient vous voir faut-il qu
est ce que vous les conseillez je lui
dit d'aller se faire vacciner
tusk
fait d'ailleurs avec mes petits enfants
donc ça montre que j'y crois parce que
je pense que même si dans la très très
grande majorité des cas l'infection et
bening bien sûr le site ici à faire une
déclaration qui est un peu passé
inaperçu en france d'ailleurs qui
souligne qu' il est quand même pas non
plus exceptionnel d'avoir des
complications pas du tout forcément
mortelle mais les vrais complications
chez des adolescents parce que c'est
parfois extrêmement fatigant pour un
adolescent que ça peut avoir un
retentissement important et d'autre part
parce que les vaccins actuels ont fait
la preuve de leur innocuité et qu'ils
sont efficaces surtout les variants les
vaccins en particulier à rl mais un
moindre degré mais quand même de façon
très significative donc je suis d'accord
avec madame haroche que c'est sur une
décision qui est un peu difficile enfin
à l'arrivée je suis très positif et je
pense que c'est que c'est pas seulement
justement contrairement à ce qu'on
entend quelquefois une mesure altruiste
seat rhuys et c'est bien d'être
altruiste mais c'est également une
protection une protection personnelle et
si tout le monde joue le jeu et si on y
arrive
eh bien on retrouvera une vie normale et
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
aux états unis on y reviendra peut-être
michel de lorgeril vous vous êtes
médecin épidémiologiste chercheur au
cnrs velp auteur de nombreux livres sur
les oméga 3 sur le cholestérol et sur
les vaccins le dernier s'intitule les
vaccins à l'air de lakovic 19 philae
paru chez kiwi même cas de figure
j'ai entre 12 et 14 ans je viens vous
voir qu'est ce que vous me conseiller
alors je suis un médecin et je suis un
scientifique et par conséquent face à un
produit de santé avant de donner des
conseils je me renseigne je m'informe et
j'essaie de comprendre un peu quelles
sont les données existantes concernant
les vaccins concernés donc pour le mot
man le vaccin qui est proposé aux
adolescents c'est le trailer
qu'est ce que j'ai comme données
concernant l'efficacité
elles sont très fragiles qu'est ce que
j'ai comme données concernant
l'innocuité elles sont très fragiles
mellino qtc un problème secondaire on
peut accepter les effets indésirables
d'un vaccin chez des individus ou dans
une collectivité mais à condition qu'on
ne soit qu on se sûr d'avoir des
bénéfices est pour le moment avec le
vaccin de pfizer comme avec les autres
vaccins les bénéfices démontré son songe
ne sont pas démontrés tout simplement as
et les et les essais cliniques qui nous
sont proposées la façon dont ils ont été
menés sont son sont médiocres et
d'ailleurs les autorités sanitaires
internationales et nationales non
autorisée s'est produit mais que de
façon provisoire six ils deviennent
s'ils deviennent définitivement
autorisée sur la bi sur le marché il
faudra qu'ils aient des données
supplémentaires
or il n'y aura pas de données
supplémentaires probablement donc là la
question principale c'est est ce que
nous avons des données solides montrant
l'efficacité du vaccin pfizer la réponse
est non chez les adultes c'est pas
solide c'est même très mauvais et chez
les adolescents on n'a quasiment rien du
tout c'est à dire 0 publication montrant
l'efficacité de ces de ce vaccin donc je
vois pas comment vu la faiblesse des
données scientifiques etc c'est mon
métier je pourrais conseiller à
quelqu'un d'administrer ou de recevoir
ce type de produits de santé alors je
juste un mot il y a des règles très
précises concernant les autorisations de
mise sur le marché pour les produits de
santé est très paradoxalement ces règles
ne sont pas respectées pour les vaccins
c'est pas uniquement avec les bacs senti
qu vide c'est aussi avec d'autres
vaccins est donc là on est face à une
problématique qui te la fois
scientifique médical éthique et qui est
traité de manière très superficielle
dans les médias
conventionnelle on va dire ça comme ça
mais aussi par les autorités sanitaires
angela sultan vous êtes chercheuse en
économie expérimentale labeur gundy
school of business qui se trouve à dijon
comme son nom ne l'indiqué pas vous avez
créé le laissac le laboratoire
d'expérimentation sciences sociales et
analyse des comportements vous ce qu'ils
veulent at elle jamais ça c'est ce que
c'est de comprendre les comportements et
par contre pourquoi va-t-on ne va-t-on
pas se faire vacciner par exemple alors
qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez un
adolescente l'adolescent enfin il ne
prend pas la décision pour lui même
en fait moi je voudrais revenir à
l'origine de cette de ce consentement à
la vaccination
l'adolescent va passer par le
consentement de ses parents
et donc on est dans un cas précis dans
laquelle on a une situation
d'incertitude dans laquelle les
individus fonctionne sur des heures
ristic et là c'est ce sont les parents
qui vont contre qui vont fonctionner sur
des heuristiques c'est à dire des des
règles rationnelle un peu approximative
qui vont faire que je vais prendre des
décisions qui sont satisfaisantes n'être
pas tout à fait optimale sur la base de
ce que je sais et promeut disaient les
médecins que vous avez invité je ne sais
pas grand chose donc je suis dans une
situation d'incertitude
donc je suis obligé par pas raccourci
cognitif en fait de donner plus de plus
d'importance à la force de l'évidence
qu'au poids de l'évidence c'est à dire
que s'il ya des situations extrêmes dans
lequel dans lesquelles il pourrait se
passer quelque chose de mal avec cette
vaccination des adolescents je vais les
avons beaucoup plus en tête lorsque je
décide de la vaccination pour mémé
adolescents que le nombre de fois où ce
6 s'est passé et danse dans cette
situation là en tant qu' il s'agit en
fait semblant de faire des choix pour
les autres dont l'un je fais pas le
choix pour me vacciner moi en tant
qu'adulte mais je fais le chat de 20 mm
ou d'adolescents et dans ce cas là en
fait je fais face à ce qu'on appelle la
version à la perte tout simplement parce
que là pour l'instant je suis dans une
situation de statu quo dans laquelle il
se ça se passe bien je n'ai rien à
perdre or quand je fais un choix pour
les autres la version à la perte va être
renversé
c'est à dire que si ces quelques monde
par qui je suis lié émotionnellement 2
manière très forte je vais être beaucoup
plus affectée par la version à la perte
que si je faisais un choix pour moi même
et si les choix sont alignés c'est à
dire que je fais les mêmes choses pour
moi et pour cet individu là je vais
avoir une espèce de surréaction demi de
mon système cognitif tout simplement à
la perte qui me parle plus que le gain
qui peut en découler vu que le gars en
fait je n'ai pas d'informations assez
suffisante dessus donc pour l'instant
moi ce que je dirai à l'adolescence
cessé de discuter avec les parents qui
malheureusement nous n'aurons pas de
choix est clair et non plus et donc du
coup de de prendre en compte le fait que
l' architecture de choix qui nous est
proposé en ce moment un terme de
politique de santé en fait en france
n'est pas complet donc on ne peut pas
vraiment faire un choix éclairé
elle reviendra aux 4,2 fait d'eux les
sens mais il ya d'abord celui des
soignants qui refusent enfin il y en a
une partie d'entre eux qui refusent de
se faire vacciner
qu'est ce qui pourrait justifier de
rendre le vaccin obligatoire comme il en
est question pour certaines professions
et notamment pour les soignants est ce
que vous avez
réfléchi à ça au journal international
de médecine oui oui on a fait un sondage
qui a montré que 62 % des problèmes de
santé étaient pour la vaccination
obligatoire contre la cosi des soignants
et mais c'était beaucoup plus fort chez
les médecins et les pharmaciens qui
étaient 90 % et alors que les
infirmières étaient plutôt contre en
fait mais donc ce qui rend légitime
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
c'est que la cosi de c'est une maladie
nosocomiale qui a eu beaucoup de cas
d'infection dans les ehpad et donc c'est
ça qu'ils ont évidemment j'étais pas
dans les palais aussi dans les hôpitaux
aussi donc ça c'est vraiment voilà et
que en plus on est face à un vaccin qui
est très efficace alors que avec la
grippe pour laquelle elle avec sa
descente de 14,6 posée le vaccin est
moins efficace donc voila et donc c'est
pour ça il ya aussi parce que les
soignants eux-mêmes comme des christian
bréchot sur la vaccination des
adolescents là c'est encore plus vrai
pour les soignants les soignants eux
mêmes ont payé un lourd tribut il ya
beaucoup de soignants qui sont morts de
la commune donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya
beaucoup de raisons pour rendre la
vaccination des soignants obligatoires
et puis c'est aussi une question
d'exemplarité voilà il ya d'autres
vaccins pour les soignants qui sont
gator comme l'hépatite b donc c'est ça
s'inscrirait dans la continuité
et justement en jeu angers la sultane
est-ce que tu rendras vaccins
obligatoires même pour une catégorie de
la population
c'est toujours dangereux parce que ça
renforce encore encore plus ceux qui
sont contre les vaccins
vous vous conseillez quoi en tant que
chercheuse en est que de me expert
comporte expérimental et
comportementales je ne pense pas qu'il
faut qu'on aille jusqu'à là à rendre ce
vaccin obligatoire il ya des moyens
beaucoup moins coûteux et beaucoup plus
accepter en fait qui existe
il ya un moyen très simple on a démontré
que si on
propose aux individus est ce qu'on
appelle une option octobre c'est à dire
un rendez vous par défaut pour la
vaccination avec la possibilité de le
changer ou de l'annuler cognitivement il
va être difficile de se défaire de ce
rendez vous là et donc nous allons avoir
beaucoup de personnes qui iront se faire
vacciner
donc il suffit en gros de convoquer les
individus pour un bac 5 sans le rendre
obligatoire et ils viendront y aura des
taux d'acceptation qui sont fort je ne
pense pas qu'il faut qu'on aille jusqu'à
jusqu'aux fêtes de rendre obligatoire
pour certaines populations ceci étant
dit c'est une situation qui est rare en
fait parce que en france quand même on a
tout un tas de vaccins qui sont déjà
obligatoires et on en discute presque
plus beau fait rien il ya les
changements vaccinale pour les enfants
voilà pour les enfants mais pour les
adultes qui ont la liberté de choix
quand même même si on décide de rendre
une vaccination obligatoire
il ya ce qu'on appelle le paternalisme
libertaire qui fait qu'on peut donner
aux gens l'impression qu'ils ont encore
le choix en les contraignant à aller se
faire vacciner voix est ce que je vous
propose c'est ce que je vous dis là le
obstacle c'est une sorte d'obligation
mais qu'on ne parle ne comprend pas
comme ça parce que je ne pense pas qu'en
france on puisse réagir positivement une
obligation donné comme ça michel de
lorgeril oui qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui
pourrait justifier à vos yeux qu'on
rende le vaccin vaccin obligatoire
auprès des soignants
alors il faudrait évidemment que ce
vaccin soit efficace il faut que la
démonstration de cette efficacité soit
indiscutable pour des vrais et des vrais
scientifiques vraiment indépendant de
l'industriel et là on revient aux
vaccins pfizer j'insiste un tout petit
peu le seul essai clinique qui était été
conduit
à ce jour et qui était et qui a été
publiée dans le new england journal of
medecine en décembre 2020 c'est un essai
qui est bâclé qui tu arrêtais de manière
de manière prématurée le nombre le
nombre de cas graves est ridiculement
petit tous les investigateurs sont des
employés du fabricant de testeurs du
brevet de pfizer
enfin bref tout ce qu'il faut pas faire
dans un essai clinique pour qu'il soit
acceptable par des scientifiques je veux
dire des vrais scientifiques qui ont
vraiment conduit les essais cliniques
qui savent de quoi ils parlent en
épidémiologie d'intervention tout a été
mal fait ce qui fait que les résultats
de l'essai father n'est pas crédible
je vais vous donner juste un exemple un
exemple que je trouve presque terrible
hein tous les médias conventionnels ont
clamé que ce vaccin diminuer la
mortalité due aux coûts vite bon pour
démontrer la un effet sur la mortalité
par un vaccin il faut un essai clinique
c'est la seule manière crédible de
démontrer l'efficacité sur la mortalité
et bien je vous pose la question combien
il ya de morts duo kobe dedans l'essai
de files ont fait part 0 c'est vraiment
le problème principal qu'on a en ce
moment c'est que beaucoup de gens
parlent sans avoir lu les essais
cliniques alors dans l'essai clinique de
pfizer il ya zéro décès comment peut-on
après clamer que ce vaccin sauvent des
vies ou à diminuer la mortalité alors
évident je comprends bien que les gens
ont besoin d'être rassurés qu'on a
besoin de dire des choses qu'il faut
occuper les plateaux de télé etc
et alors on va se se rassurer en prenant
des données d'épidémiologie
d'observation et comme vous sert en
sciences médicales il y a deux
l'important dans domaine c'est
l'épidémiologie d'observation qui est
une science médicale on va dire
extrêmement faible sur lequel on ne peut
jamais donner des montres et des
relations de causalité est d'ailleurs
jamais une autorité de santé va
autoriser la mise sur le marché d'un
produit uniquement sur la base de
l'épidémiologie d'observation donc c'est
à mettre de côté et c'est l'autre
l'autre domaine c'est l'épidémiologie
d'intervention tous les médicaments qui
sont autorisés sur le marché aujourd'hui
moderne a en tout cas ont eu alors
conduit de manière plus ou moins bonne
je suis prêt à le discuter
mais c'est de l'épidémiologie
d'intervention des essais cliniques ont
tant que l'on appelle essai clinique
randomisé en double aveugle a évidemment
il faut que les investigateurs soit
indépendant du sponsor au minimum
surtout si ce n'est pas de la veulent
dans les 7 févr
c'est un essai randomisé mais s'il n'est
pas conduit en double aveugle c'est
d'ailleurs là la précaution minimale des
essais cliniques ne sont pas respectés
et donc par exemple mais 7,7 c'est
exactement la même chose pour les autres
essais cliniques ne sont pas respectés
dans les faits leur aise il suffit de
lire la première page de l'article
c'est un essai qui est observeur blind 1
pour les ans pour les anglophones c'est
facile c'est pas facile à comprendre ce
qu'ils veulent dire
après il faut ce qu'il faut et étudier
la méthodologie qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait exactement ça veut dire que les
seringues étaient simplement
reconnaissable et par l'infirmière ou le
technicien qui et administre le vaccin
et par le patient aussi donc on n'est
pas en double aveugle
est ce cette précaution indispensable
qui est requise par toutes les autorités
sanitaires n'est pas respectée les
spyder
donc c'est pas crédible je suis pas en
train de dire que ce vaccin n'est pas
obligatoire
en fait je suis en train de dire que les
données qui me sont présentés ne me
permettent pas de conclure dit dans un
sens
le vaccin est efficace mais je ne peux
pas dire non plus que le vaccin est
inefficace
en fait j'en sais rien
quand je ne sais pas comme médecin
qu'est ce que je fais je m'abstiens
c'est la règle basique de la médecine
depuis l'antiquité
d'abord ne pas nuire et ensuite dans le
doute je m'abstiens tayssir bresso
ben si vous voulez je suis d'accord avec
monsieur de lorgeril sur le fait qu'il
faut raisonner et qu'il faut alors il a
une petite tendance monsieur leur jury a
considéré qu'il est le chercheur le
médecin et la personne qui réfléchit et
que ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec
lui ne réfléchissent pas dans le
voudrais simplement rappeler que il nous
a fait bon une grande démonstration sur
le fait qu'il avait tout analysé
j'aurais resituer des choses je pense
que c'est une bonne discussion et je dis
pas soit par diplomatie que se posaient
des questions donc il ya rien d'agressif
dans ce que je vais dire mais on est
dans un sujet tellement important que je
trouve que personne ne peut aller
prendre comme on disait avant le
monopole de de la réflexion c'est c'est
très très mauvais je trouve d'autres
comme ça je représente un groupe ii le
global voice networks étaient 65 centres
de scientifiques de renom mais je vous
ai écoutés monsieur donc vous me laissez
parler les donc ça ça représente 65
centres de recherche dans le monde de
gens qui sont des vrais grands
scientifiques et je ne prétends pas que
monsieur laurent jury ne soit pas un
très bon scientifique qui sont
indépendants c'est le global varie
stature qui est indépendante je trouve
que cette manière de toujours dire que
les gens qui défendent des vaccins sont
des vendus à l'industrie est d aider
vendus et désagréable je trouve que
c'est pas comme ça qu'on avance
donc je m'inscris en faux avec ce qu'a
dit monsieur lors jury sur son analyse
de l'efficacité du vaccin et je voudrais
vraiment j'espère pouvoir être entendu
parce que je trouve ça un peu terrible
les études cliniques y en a pas du tout
que une is it new england
il y en a eu bien sûr d'autres qui ont
été publiés dans le monde entier des
études à des niveaux nationaux
internationaux il y en a eu en australie
en a eu dont il faut vraiment faire la
littérature elles ont été bien fait
les études observationnelles monsieur
lorgeril a soulevé un point qui est très
important c'est la valeur des études
observationnelles mais jamais on avec
des conclusions différentes danses au
contraire que ce qui a été parce que
encore une fois avant les études
cliniques je connais bien aussi
vraiment je dirais et les personnes
descente que je représente connaissent
très bien
c'est tellement important c'est pour ça
que me permet d'être un peu incisif
parce que c'est vraiment très important
ce qu'on discute pense que c'est
peut-être le seul point où on est
d'accord
donc si vous voulez des études cliniques
elles ont été faites elles ont été bien
faites et le fait de faire des études
observationnelles c'est très bien
beaucoup d'erreurs en médecine ont été
basées sur le fait qu' on s'est basé sur
des études cliniques randomisées
rigoureuse mais toujours fait par
justement dans un contexte particulier
avec des patients qui étaient pas
volontairement sélectionné mais qui
représentait des france particulière et
c'est quand on passe en population
quand on passe dans la vraie vie et
quand vous voyez les résultats qui ont
été montrés par les autorités
israéliennes par ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis où je vis ou oui bien sûr le
vaccin diminue la mortalité et s'est
montrée avec des chiffres qui sont très
importants oui bien sûr on agit sur la
circulation du virus
oui bien sûr et sans n'en parle jamais
au delà de la mort qui évidemment une
catastrophe le nombre de gens dont on
parle très peu qui ont des formes
extrêmement fatigant de co vide qui vont
être complètement dans un état vraiment
difficile pendant un mois deux mois
on sait également maintenant qui est ce
qu'on appelle les longues roller les
locaux vides qui représente en fait dans
certaines études qui ont été publiés 25
à 30% des gens qui sont qui sont
infectés
toutes ces personnes là oui les vaccins
s'est montrée actuellement permettent
d'agir sur ses manières l'a donc si vous
voulez je pense que il ya une
démonstration qui n'a peut-être jamais
été fait en vaccination humaine au delà
de l'efficacité d'un vaccin
c'est une approche qui n'est pas du tout
uniquement moi je voudrais simplement
dire que je suis un porte parole deux
scientifiques c'est pour ça que j'ai
réagi en étant un peu choqué quand on
nous fait la leçon c'est que de gens qui
réfléchissent de gens qui sont
indépendants de gens qui ont analysé des
études et il faut que alors à de là
découle ma réponse est ce que la
vaccination doit être obligatoire pour
les soignants absolument je suis
entièrement d'accord avec madame laroche
dessus c'est très bien de se poser des
questions j'ai dirigé un service
clinique pendant des années j'ai vu ce
qui s'est passé dans certaines
vaccinations qui n'était pas obligatoire
et oui effectivement la vaccination doit
être obligatoire parce qu'on traite des
gens parce qu'on s'occupe des gens parce
que ça fait partie du serment qu on a
passé quand on est un médecin et donc la
vaccination doit être obligatoire chez
les soignants
il n'y a pas de honte à demander une
obligation pour actuellement pour quand
on veut voyager on doit avoir la fièvre
jaune
on doit avoir le vaccin eh bien il
faudra qu'on soit capable d'assumer ce
genre de choses je crois qu'on arrive à
un moment où il faut prendre nos
responsabilités et les responsabilités
c'est d'être capable de dire eh bien
écoutez oui on a un vaccin qui est
efficace
encore une fois pour les adolescents moi
je maintiens mon point sur le fait qu'
il ya des formes qui sont fatigantes qui
sont sûrs il n'y a pas seulement des
gens qui vont en réanimation les
contrats pas dans les statistiques
monsieur de leurs jurys ne les verra pas
dans ces articles
mais ces gens là ils existent et ya
aucune raison de penser tenir compte
ce vaccin est efficace quand on dit ce
on a eu plusieurs on parle pas des
autres il a montré et ce je pense que ça
n'est je pense que c'est pas bien de
démolir ces vaccins alors amo de
d'aurélie à roche juste avant la pause
on a deux minutes dans la vaccination
des soignants ou
sur wii je pense que la vaccination des
soignants et la vaccination des années
d'éditions c'est pas du tout la même
chose
après alors mais je trouve que les deux
sont liés en ce moment et c'est voilà
parlent en même temps je suis tout à
fait convaincu et de l'efficacité du
vaccin et du thé faibles risques
associés bon après chez les adolescents
comme le bénéfice est un peu moindre la
question du risque se pose un peu plus
mais c'est sûr que ces vaccins ne sont
pas risqués et c'est sûr qu'ils sont
efficaces et on l'a vu en effet en
israël etc
mais c'est pas parce que des vaccins
sont efficaces qu'il faut les rendre
obligatoires il ya la question et l'air
un peu différente et une des questions
éthiques et la question du consentement
est très importante donc qu'est-ce que
c'est un consentement quand on oblige
les gens et c'est un petit peu difficile
as couvent est dans une société où on
passe outre le consentement des gens et
on passe outre leur liberté il ya une
liberté à vouloir ne pas être vaccinés
on peut on peut le concevoir
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya jamais eu de
vaccins qui ont été rendus obligatoires
pour les adultes
est-ce que je me trouve en guyane le
vaccin contre la fièvre jaune est
obligatoire pour toute la population
donc souvent les gens sont accélérées
jeunes mais après ils doivent être mais
pour les adultes non c'est plus
compliqué pour un adulte puisque comment
on contrôle pour les enfants on contrôle
quand ils rentrent à l'école quand ils
vont chez le pédiatre pour un adulte
pour on ne contrôle pas mais on pourrait
imaginer un contrôle
l'assurance maladie pourrait checker
tous les gens qui n'ont pas été vaccinés
les appeler ans et l'or à les appeler
trois fois et un bout de la troisième
fois il ya eu des rendez vous comme le
groupe c'est vrai qu'en plus c'est des
étapes avant l'obligation on n'est pas
obligé de mais après politiquement aussi
c'est une grande question c'est est-ce
que politiquement on peut rendre
obligatoire la vaccination des soignants
c'est plus facile des plus fragiles
c'est encore une autre question
et puis la question c'est aussi que mais
par contre dans la question de la
vaccination désolé sens et on va
proposer aux adolescents de se vacciner
on va les y inciter fortement alors
qu'il ya des personnes âgées vulnérables
qui passe à travers et auquel on le dit
il n'y avait d'ailleurs la question je
vais vous poser juste après une pause
[Musique]
il ne cesse d'augmenter et devrait
atteindre cette année 9 4% du pib
français
un record on parle bien sûr du déficit
public quand vous avez un déficit de
près de 10% et que vous allez faire
peut-être quatre peut-être 5% de
croissance
on n'en sait rien pour l'instant eh bien
vous êtes en récession de 6 quoi en gros
c'est ça que ça veut dire n'est plus tôt
dans une stratégie de dirigeants lahlou
t1 après moi le déluge
mais le déluge s'il va finir par arriver
si l'on continue à voir ce type de
désinvolture et d'insouciance vis-à-vis
de la situation de nos finances
publiques qui a beaucoup d'activités qui
sont plus habiles bras et qui le jour où
il n'y a plus de lignes à plus d' aides
vont s'effondrer devons continuer à
espérer et dans l'efficacité d'un plan
de relance qui est totalement
inappropriée et totalement
perpendiculaires aux besoins de
l'économie française
[Musique]
vous allez vous vous consacrez au
festival du film russe à paris qui est
intitulé quand les russes 2 bouleverse
nous bouleverse toujours vous savez
parce qu'on les comprend pas il nous
touche
ils nous font pleurer et on sait pas
pourquoi l'objectif réel profond que
vous avez là c'est quoi c'est de faire
de la pédagogie c'est de faire mieux que
ça c'est de recréer des liens que la
politique n'arrive plus à renault alors
c'est à dire que la culture c'est au
dessus de tout ça le cinéma nous dit des
vérités que nous disent personne ni les
politiques ni les ambassadeurs ni les
journalistes et nous sommes prêts c'est
la même culture c'est la même façon de
penser
les mêmes physique je pense qu'il ya une
union qui va se rétablir c'est pas
possible autrement
et toute façon ils ont besoin de nous
comme nous avons besoin je suis
optimiste tête pas tout de suite il faut
passer au delà de quelques quelques
obstacles mais je crois que l'avenir et
aliments
moment
[Musique]
repro ce débat avec aurélie à roche qui
rédactrice en chef de jim point fr le
journal international de médecine avec
christian bréchot qui est virologue et
qui a été le directeur général à la fois
de l'institut mérieux de l'inserm et de
l'institut pasteur avec michel de
lorgeril qu'est médecin chercheur auteur
du livre les vaccins de l'ère de la
queue vide de 19 aux éditions kiwi et
angela sultane qui est chercheuse en
économie comportementale angela sultane
venons-en au cadet adolescent maintenant
oublions les soignants on va on peut
avoir l'impression quand on est le père
ou la mère d'un adolescent quand un état
dans le temps et ce en soi même qu'on
lui demande aujourd'hui de se faire
vacciner
non pas tant pour lui mais parce qu'il
ya des adultes ou des vieillards qui eux
soit ont peur soit refusent de se faire
vacciner confo c'est lui qui va aller se
faire vacciner à leur place est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous lui rendiez je le dis
je le dis d'autant plus qu' on sait
qu'il est pas très facile d'être jeune
aujourd'hui on vous a enfermé chez vous
pendant un certain temps on a fermé vos
écoles et aujourd'hui dès que vous vous
rassemblez on vous envoie la police la
police qui en plus détruits généralement
les instruments de musique à peu près
tout ce que vous avez apporté pour pour
passer un bon moment et tout le monde
trouve ça normal
donc je suis adolescent je suis patient
que j'ai envie de rendre service à la
société en ce moment envoyé
qu'est ce que vous lui dites à celui là
alors à celui là je lui dis jusqu'à il a
le comportement typique de son groupe
d'âge je m'explique
en fait il est beaucoup plus facile de
dissuader un adolescent de faire quelque
chose de mal que de le
convaincre de faire quelque chose de
bien mais c'est un des billets humains
les plus connus au now cette balance là
qu'on fait entre coûts et avantages
lorsqu'on est adolescent nous on veut
faire du bien les adolescents dont une
fonction altruiste qui est beaucoup plus
développé que nous les les adultes et
qui sont beaucoup plus sensibles à tout
un tas de problèmes l'environnement
l'égalité et la non-discrimination etc
mais par contre ils sont plus sensibles
également à ce qu'enfin ils sont plus
averses au risque
on croit qu'un adolescent c'est un peu
n'importe quoi mais en fait il prend
moins de risques quand l'adulte et donc
du coup quand on lui dit va te faire
vacciner pour les autres donc on te
demande une contribution altruiste aux
biens publics en fait vous fait que la
population soit soient vaccinés il est
tiraillé entre de comportement d'un côté
je voudrais aller me faire vacciner
parce que je suis justement je fais
partie de cette population là qui fait
des efforts altruiste la plupart du
temps mais de l'autre côté en fait je
suis victime de ce qu'on appelle un
biais guy média tu t'es les adolescents
sont encore plus victimes que nous les
adultes de ce biais là le biais de
l'immédiateté c'est quoi c'est qu'en
fait mes préférences temporelles
on ne fonctionne pas de manière
constante conte comment dire j'ai signé
obtient l'égard de futurs
et le problème c'est que si j'ai mis un
pied à l'égard du futur même si je
m'engage aujourd'hui à prendre des
décisions responsables pour demain
demant quand viendra le jour où il faut
que je prenne cette décision là en fait
je ne serais pas capable de me tenir en
mai à mes engagements et donc ce que je
suis en train de dire c'est que encore
une fois je jauge euros mais le problème
en place il faut pas aller dire à
l'adolescent va te faire vacciner faut
aller dire aux parents va aller faire
vacciner vos enfants parce que
l'adolescent il va être d'une part au
mais victime de ces biais là que je
viens de citer
et d'autre part il va il va porter sur
ses épaules une responsabilité qui n'est
pas la sienne
ce qu'il faut convaincre d'aller se
faire vacciner eux mêmes et d'aller
faire vacciner leurs enfants sont
adultes et encore une fois donc on a des
manières douces ou pour essayer de les
faire vacciner
on peut aller bien sûr jusqu'à
l'obligation qu'on vous le disiez tout à
l'heure mais en fait ça critique en gros
vous dit phil architecture de choix et
qu'on passe c'est un nouveau type
d'intervention publique en fait sur
lequel on va on va et précis si on passe
vraiment sur une obligation ou pas sur
un autre type d'intervention publique
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça serait
quand même dangereux de reporter
l'obligation de la vaccination sur les
épaules des adolescents parce qu'on vous
avait dit ce sont des individus qui ont
souffert de cette crise qui en sont
sortis avec des séquelles et on va pas
le refaire en plus porter la
responsabilité du fait qu'on n'a pas
attendre l'immunité collective et donc
je pense qu'il faut retourner le
problème et se concentrait plus sur les
parents il ya tous ces gens là qui sont
indécis
c'est eux qu'il faut convaincre d'aller
se faire vacciner avant tayssir bréchot
bas je trouve que je suis vraiment tout
à fait d'accord sur le fait que et avait
ce que ce qui vient d'être dit sur est
ce que vous avez dit aussi on peut pas
aller demander à des adolescents dessert
vacciner uniquement en leur disant
écoutez voilà vous êtes là pour vous
faire vacciner parce que il faut
prévenir des formes graves chez les gens
âgés et puis et puis effectivement il y
en a là dedans dans les gens âgés qui
n'acceptent pas de se faire vacciner
donc c'est comme ça il faut été
instruits c'est tout moi je trouve que
c'est vraiment une manière de poser des
choses qui n'est pas exact et je suis
entièrement d'accord avec le fait que la
vaccination chez les adolescents ne peut
se discuter que si un effort vrai énorme
pour passer le plateau de verre et pour
vacciner les personnes les plus âgées ce
qui veut dire s'en donner les moyens
il faut prendre une seconde là dessus
parce que sinon la vaccination des ados
n'a pas de chance et c'est ce qui se
passe par exemple aux états unis où
après une diminution importante du vague
de la vaccination
ça semble aller mieux parce qu'ils se
donnent les moyens d'aller dans les
zones rurales de trouver des personnes
qui pour des raisons également sociale
enfin il faut vraiment voir les choses
que ne peuvent pas se faire vacciner
donc ça n'a pas de chance de discuter la
vaccination chez les adolescents s'il
n'y a pas un énorme effort visible pour
les adolescents visible pour l'ensemble
de la population pour que l'ensemble des
personnes âgées mais aussi fragiles
soient vaccinés et on dit ça moi je
reviens sur ce que je disais tout à
l'heure je suis un peu surpris quand on
nous dit et je partage pas complètement
avec d'autres personnes du global avoir
investi est forte dans d'autres pays
finalement les adolescents dans leur
demande de se vacciner pour les autres
parce que évidemment quand ils font un
kobe de 19 il leur arrive rien là ça
n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas vrai
médicalement et il faut dire la vérité
aux adolescents il faut leur dire que
effectivement ils font beaucoup moins de
forme grave
ils vont beaucoup moins en réanimation
heureusement et donc par définition on a
beaucoup moins qui meurt et c'est même
très rare et heureusement mais ça n'est
pas uniquement salle cosy 19
je crois qu'il ya vraiment un espèce de
il faut voir dans sa globalité ce qu'est
le la médecine justement du coc vie 19
et ça ça paraît un point très important
dans la manière dont on présente ça ou
aux adolescents donc je crois que
personnellement j'ai demandé à mes
petits-enfants d'aller se faire vacciner
ce qu'ils ont fait très bien et est mais
avec pas en leur disant tu te dévouent
pour pour moi je suis vacciné évidemment
mais tu te dévouent pour les personnes
de mon âge parce que je trouve que c'est
que c'est pas que c'est pas suffisant
donc je suis d'accord avec le fait qu'il
faut associer ça a un vrai fort au delà
des mots de l'ada positions politiques
sur la vaccination des gens plus âgés et
des gens fragiles je termine en disant
une chose qu'on est en train de voir
partout on l'a vu au brésil on commence
à le voir en inde
on le voit dans beaucoup de pays avec
l'efficacité de la vaccination chez les
personnes âgées les gens qu'on retrouve
en réanimation et ça se trouve apparaît
actuellement il faut aller voir quand
même des choses ce sont des gens qui
sont beaucoup plus jeunes et ce fantasme
qui est les gens jeunes se font vacciner
parce que les vieux
on veut le point de faire ça c'est il
faut que ça s'arrête il faut que ça
s'arrête c'est comme ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
il faut qu'on revienne sur des bases
qu'ils soient des bases réelles
michel de lorgeril oui bah je suis tout
à fait d'accord il faut revenir sur des
bases réelles ce intérieur des bases
scientifiques c'est la médecine pendant
des siècles elle est née weiss à se
disputer il faut faut-il mettre les
gousses d'ail au pied du lit du courant
ou à la tête dudit du mourant c'est
toute l'histoire l'avait-il défaites que
de discussions un peu de type bavardages
et puis de disputes qui servait à rien
le vingtième siècle surtout la deuxième
partie du 20e siècle a permis un bond
considérable dans la médecine
scientifique c'est ce bond considérable
ce sont les essais cliniques randomisés
en double aveugle j'y reviens et alors
j'y reviens de deux manières j'aimerais
bien développé un tout petit peu
premièrement à propos des adolescents si
on propose un vaccin aux adolescents la
première chose à faire c'est de leur
dire que ça sert à quelque chose
autre monique ce vaccin est efficace
pour les protéger eux mais aussi pour
empêcher la contagiosité c'est à dire la
dissémination à partir de ces deux
choses là ne sont pas démontrés
scientifiquement en tout cas alors on
peux bavarder dire qu'on a la conviction
que que jour n'a vu que que c'est
évident que etc
maintenant ça ça ça n'a pas de sens
parce que c'est de ces deux de l'ordre
de l'observation et l'observation c'est
le nid de tous les biais et de toutes
les erreurs et par exemple en israël
alors israël c'est le pays qui a le
vacciner le plus vite et le plus sa
population et on le présente comme
l'exemple indépassable mais ces deux
observations
c'est pas un essai clinique qu'on a fait
en israël et alors qu'est ce que l'on
qu'est ce qu'on a vu en vérité en israël
et si on ouvre
je sais qu'il ya eu trois choses en même
temps premièrement ait eu un pic
épidémique mais toutes les flambées
épidémiques arrive à un pic puis
descendent naturellement sans qu'on
fasse quoi que ce soit c'est ce qu'on a
vu alors on peut aider un peu un par
exemple un confinement peut aider à
atteindre le pic et puis la redescente
la régression de la flambée épidémique
donc le confinement est vraiment quelque
chose de très efficace
et puis troisièmement donc je reprends
l'extinction naturelle de la flambée
petit peut être définitive ou
transitoires c'est probablement ce qui
se passe dans de nombreux pays où on
vaccine pas et qu'on finit pas ou très
peu
deuxièmement le confinement en israël
ils ont ils ont été un petit peu laxiste
avec le premier confinement par contre
le troisième de deuxième silhouette si
c'était 17 s'est elle même
là ils ont été d'une rigueur extrême c
était quelque chose d'extraordinaire en
sortait plus en israël
et c'est ça c'est efficace ça c'est
efficace ya pas y'a pas d'essai clinique
mais là c'était tellement évident que
personne ne peut le discuter
et en même temps il ya eu la vaccination
alors que l'on puisse dire que c'est la
vaccination qui a permis l'extraction
peut-être transitoire j'espère
définitive de l'épidémie en israël c'est
une erreur vous avez trois facteurs qui
ont contribué dire que c'est la
vaccination c'est abusif
en tout cas c'est pas scientifique
d'autant plus que dans certains pays il
ya une courbe parallèle entre la
vaccination et l'épidémie 1 on a vu ça
au chili on a vu ça en mongolie on a vu
au nom du sein dans d'autres pays et
donc il faut tenir compte de tous et si
vous restez au niveau observationnelles
bas vous allez vous disputer vous allez
dire oui j'ai la conviction que je pense
que il est évident que non ça c'est pas
bon c'est pas de la science on a appris
au xxème siècle surtout 21e siècle c'est
les essais cliniques qui permettent de
démontrer l'efficacité chez les
adolescents est ce que le vaccin pas
faiseur et efficace qu'est ce qu'on a
comme document qui nous permettent
d'évaluer l'efficacité du trader chez
les adolescents écoutez on n'a rien
oui quand je dis rien à rien sinon des
rapports de l'industriel aux médias
comment voulez vous que des
scientifiques évaluent un vaccin
correctement dans une population
spécifique
s'ils n'ont pas les documents
indispensables à ce travail
donc aujourd'hui on est dans cette
tournée aujourd'hui exactement dans
cette problématique
pas de données comment voulez-vous
conclure comment on va t'on évaluer la
contagiosité comment va-t-on évalué que
la vaccination des adolescents va
diminuer la contagiosité vers le vert
les les autres on va dire ça les hautes
sphères le principe du vaccin altruiste
n'y a pas de démonstration scientifique
on pourrait le faire on aurait pu le
faire mais on l'a pas fait exactement
comme les essais cliniques avec le
vaccin de pfizer
on aurait pu très bien travaillé on
aurait pu attendre un peu on aurait pu
faire du double aveugle
on aurait pu confier l'essai clinique à
des investigateurs qui ne soient pas des
employés du sponsor ouailles un peu le
conflit d'intérêts ce sont les employés
du sponsor tir de taser qui conduisent
l'étude tout leur intérêt
évidemment c'est que ça marche c'est
leur salaire c'est leur carrière c'est
leur avenir c'est leur ambition et c'est
donc ça s'éteint c'est un biais
tellement majeur qu'il est
incompréhensible que personne ne le voit
mais je sais que beaucoup le voient mais
surtout que personne ne le disent il
faut arrêtez donc de prendre les données
d'observation comme des données
définitif et on a été je pense au cours
des derniers mois tellement déçu avec
tous ces experts qui circulent sur les
plateaux de télé des professeurs des
universitaires des académiciens je ne
cite personne mais qu'ils se sont
trompés à chaque fois et qu'ils se sont
trompés et c'est ce qu'on est en train
de voir aussi au royaume-uni 1
ils ont dit on a gagné on est les plus
forts on a le meilleur vaccin
et puis on voit que c'est pas si bon que
ça et que ça a l'air de repartir alors
on accuse le virus
c'est ridicule voyez c'est peut-être que
c'est le virus à la facette virus qui
aura le dernier mot
soit tu continues à s'amuser avec nous
soit il il va il va se reposer à voir la
prochaine étape
justement ce qu'on pourrait lire à roche
on a l'impression que les variants les
maux offensifs disparaisse et que ne
subsiste que les plus robustes qui par
leur contagiosité deviennent rapidement
les variants majoritaire s est ce que
l'on craint c'est ce qui est arrivé
d'abord avec le variant britannique
vario alpha et plus personne aujourd'hui
n'est contaminées par la souche
antérieure du virus la première celle
que celle qui nous a fait si peur au
départ le variant britannique s'est
imposé aujourd'hui on a peur du variant
delta le variant indien qui pourrait
très bien se multiplier la pendant l'été
alors l'été ça n'est pas très propre
risque en tout cas c'est ce que l'on
espère mais on redoute quand même qu'ils
deviennent majoritaires ils compris en
france à la rentrée à l'automne et on a
la pression au fond de ce sont tous ces
variants de plus en plus dangereux pour
l'homme qui vont devenir les souches
majoritaire dé souche dominante et donc
les plus résistantes maman au vaccin je
pense que le professeur vrai show sera
plus experts que moi pour parler des
variants et voilà delà de pétition
révèle variant après aujourd'hui on les
informations qu'on a qui sont en effet
pas forcément complète sur l'efficacité
du vaccin par niang pfizer sur la
variante delta elles sont plutôt
positives et encourageantes mais
évidemment ça et c'est quand même
quelque chose qu'on a besoin d'un
réflecteur aujourd'hui c'est ce qui fait
peur aujourd'hui et c'est aussi quand
même quelque chose qui doit entrer dans
la discussion du consentement à la
vaccination c'est qu'il ya quand même
ces variants et qu' il n'est pas
impossible qu'un jour gay invariants
face auquel les vaccins soit moins
efficace et ça c'est tout à fait
possible après la modélisation des
épidémies c'est toujours très compliqué
et c'est toujours très imparfait et on
ne peut pas savoir à l'avancé ce qui va
se passer et
si on va avoir un variant très dangereux
ou pas on peut aussi l inverse savoir
invariants qui se répondent beaucoup
mais qui ne soit pas du tout virulent et
soit moins virulent que les variants
historique t'es sûr bréchot je vais
répondre sur les variants mais je
voudrais répondre quand même à monsieur
de georges uhry parce que c'est quand
même un peu thierry tu as l'impression
si vous voulez qu'il ya le vrai
scientifique moi je n'aime pas que je
pense que le mépris des autres n'a
jamais conduit à quoi que ce soit je
répète ce que j'ai dit d'abord monsieur
de lorgeril il faut vous lisiez il n'y a
pas eu du tout un seul article sur les
vaccins et rennes je parle en études
cliniques parce que je suis d'accord
avec vous même si je suis en désaccord
sur les études observationnelles qu'on a
besoin d'études cliniques randomisés il
ya eu plusieurs publications il y en a
eu dans jama il y en a plusieurs à jours
gardait sur les adolescents dans bayod
archav il y en a et c'est donc il faut
qu' il faut et c'est vraiment il faut
j'espère vraiment que les personnes qui
dort bien savent que vous faites de la
pseudo-science monsieur georges urines
c'est facile de vous drapez dans le sud
médecin je suis de chercheurs et moi je
suis le professeur qui passent sur les
plateaux en faisant du bavardage et en
parlant de conviction effectivement ça
permet de faire des effets de manche
mais ça n'est pas à la réalité et j'en
mets aucune question d'ego mais c'est
dangereux pour les gens qui nous
écoutent
donc bien sûr il ya eu plusieurs
publications et pas du tout une seule
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur de
lorgeril bien sûr je ne suis pas sûr du
bavardage et de la conviction mais sûr
de la science et de la médecine
absolument au même titre que vous et non
seulement ça mais je représente et je
trouve que c'est bien
pas seulement moi même mais des gens qui
dans le monde entier sont des gens et là
vraiment je trouve que ce que vous dites
est choquant arrêtez de dire que nous
sommes vendus à l'industrie arrêtez de
dire que des gens qui publient sont des
gens qui publie pas ce que vous avez dit
vous ne citez que l'article dans fighter
mais les articles moi je vous cite sont
faits par des équipes indépendance que
vous dites est inexact
les gens qui publie actuellement des
études cliniques je parle pas d'études
observationnelles sur la vaccination
sont des gens qui ne sont pas payés par
l'industrie
il faut arrêter
donc il ya plusieurs articles ont été
publiés et donc alors maintenant pour
les variants effectivement les variants
c'est évidemment il faut savoir que pour
un virus c'est normal de varier et donc
on voit arriver des variants qui sont
effectivement plus contagieux comme le
variant delta ce qui effectivement est
un problème mais et c'est le point
essentiel
les vaccins il ya encore eu alors me il
ya une publication dans new england qui
est 10 à 15 jours monsieur de lorgeril
qui est une publication indépendante ya
pas un industriel de dents qui montrent
l'efficacité des vaccins contre les
différents variant et qui donne une
classification suivant si vous voulez le
type de sensibilité donc les vaccins
actuels sont efficaces sur les variants
et j'aime pas que vous m'interrogez même
avec déjà je fais pas tout à l'heure
j'étais en désaccord complètement avec
ce que vous disiez à aucun moment j'ai
commencé à faire des simagrées et des
gestes je crois qu'on peut quand même
respecter un peu ce que chacun dit donc
si vous voulez il est cette publication
qu une publication indépendante qui est
fait par des parts des académiques qui
sont des gens honnêtes montre
l'efficacité des vaccins sur les
différents variant et pour terminer
l'interprétation sur le royaume uni
je suis d'accord c'est une vraie
question quand on voit effectivement ce
qui s'est passé mais c'est une erreur
d'interprétation c'est à dire et
d'ailleurs personne ne l'interprètent
actuellement comme une inefficacité des
vaccins ce n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas
vrai qu'on revient vers les gens en leur
disant finalement cette ville invariants
cessenon ce qui se passe simplement
c'est que ça montre à quel point on doit
vaccinées un nombre important de
personnes
et la deuxième chose à quel point quand
on parle d'efficacité de vaccination il
faut parler des 2 12
vous avez on nous dit toujours oui c'est
formidable parce qu'on attaque signer
chez plus on à combien on est en france
il sait 45% un truc comme ça
mais ce qui compte c'est les deux doses
or au royaume uni pour des raisons de
circonstancielle il ya une grande partie
de la population qui n'a été vaccinées
que de une dose et avec le vaccin le
vaccin astrazeneca et parallèlement
il ya une diffusion massive du varié en
delta et en particulier dans les
populations jeunes et en particulier
chez des adolescents et quand vous
parlez actuellement avec des médecins
britanniques des gens qui sont pas comme
vous qui sont des gens qui regardent ce
qui se passe qui voit les gens dans les
hôpitaux
vous avez à la fois énormément
heureusement de forme complètement
bening et c'est très bien mais vous avez
malheureusement et c'est fatal plus de
gens jeunes y compris chez des
adolescents des gens qui ont 15 18 20
ans qui sont des tout jeunes qui ont des
formes qui se rangent bagarre ils vont
pas mourir ils vont pas leur réanimation
mais ils vont être épuisées pendant deux
mois ils vont interrompre leurs études
ils vont avoir et et c'est donc si vous
voulez pour résumer oui il ya beaucoup
de publication d'études cliniques
randomisés fait par des gens
indépendants c'est inexact de dire que
tout se base sur un c'est inexact de
dire qu'il n'ya jamais eu d'article chez
les adolescents les études
observationnelles sont un complément aux
études cliniques randomisées les gens
que je représente sont des gens honnêtes
indépendant et je pense qu'il faut qu'il
faut qu'on réussisse à faire passer ses
messages parce que vous êtes quelqu'un
de profondément dangereux monsieur je
suis désolé il nous reste que quelques
minutes
angela ce tag ou là je moi je voudrais
retenir la partie optimiste on est on
est dans ce qu'on appelle une confusion
en formation pour l'individu lambda il
est très difficile de comprendre ce qui
se passe qu'on n'a pas accès en tant
qu'individu aux résultats de la
recherche et je pense que donc nous les
chercheurs honda d'une part mieux
communiquer et rendre accessibles les
résultats des recherches
et la deuxième chose sur laquelle je
voudrais insister c'est que s'il faut
qu'on vaccine il ya des moyens simples
de faire vacciner et je suis désolé
c'est moins là sont connus sont prouvés
scientifiquement nous en économie
comportementale on travaille pas sur du
déclaratif on travaille nous aussi sur
des vraies comportements et ces
résultats là ça tient quatre facteurs
qu'on en fait
soit tu sois tueur influent sur les
normes sociales c'est-à-dire autour de
toi tu vois les gens qui savent qui se
vaccinent tu vas faire quand un groupe
de référence soit sont mis en avance
plutôt les risques que les bénéfices des
vaccins les individus sont plus
sensibles en fait en fait que les
dangers soient réduits quand je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure
soit tout simplement on rappelle on
rappelle aux individus qu'il faut se
vacciner soit la dernière option c ont
ras la vaccination fascine et j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'a pas assez dit
nous et ça c'est amener un con part de
la profession peut-être on n'a pas assez
dit à quel point il était facile de
rendre la vaccination facile on le sait
depuis longtemps et c'est prouvé que si
tu donnes des rendez-vous par défaut aux
individus ils vont venir se faire
vacciner
on le voit par exemple avec les enfants
ou nous envoie tout le temps
dès qu'ils sont un âge je sais pas à
partir de 7 ans le temps qu'ils nous
envoient un rendez vous par défaut vous
venez avec votre enfant voir ses dents
on pourrait aussi votre médecin traitant
ou votre employeur ou d'autres personnes
pourraient nous donner des rendez-vous
par défaut ça peut paraître compliqué
logistiquement mais c'est faisable et on
ne l'a pas fait on aurait fait ça il y
aurait eu beaucoup plus de personnes
vaccinées on n'aurait pas eu besoin de
se poser la question est-ce qu'il faut
rendre la vaccination obligatoire ou pas
je pense que si on veut faire un effort
collectif
il faut vendre là il faut rendre la
vaccination facile si jamais il ya un
danger immédiat effectivement la
facilité passe par l'obligation où on en
est là mais n'oublions certes pas moi ce
que j'entends des débats et je regrette
de pas avoir fait des études de médecine
parce que je trouve que ce que c'est
vraiment intéressant et malheureusement
je ne comprends pas tout ce que
j'entends mais moi ce que j'entends
c'est que la santé et la vaccination est
ce qu'on appelle un marché répugnant
chez nous on est à 1 sciences
comportementales appelle ça un marché
répugnant c'est à dire que rona ou on
aime pas que ce marché-là saumon et
qu'ils aient on n'aime pas que ce marché
la fonction sur la base d'incitation on
n'aime pas que ce marché la fonction sur
la base de profits mais donc du coup il
faudrait communiquer plus sur le fait
que le seul profit de tout ça c'est la
santé publique est la survie des
individus alors dernier mot michel large
de largeur il nous reste une minute 15
oui avait écouté j'ai quand même subi
des agressions multiples là alors que
moi je ne m'adresse pas spécialement à
monsieur bré chaud il supporte pas bon
scepticisme et il le montre par toutes
sortes d'agressions verbales
alors que je ne jeûne mais je n'ai rien
fait de
de la sorte ce qui est très important
est le message que je retiens de
monsieur bré show là c'est qu'il ne
comprend pas la médecine scientifique
s'est il fait pas la différence entre
des essais cliniques clic où on teste
l'effet d'un vaccin sur la maladie et
pas sur la production d'anticorps ou sur
le une charge virale et c'est dans un
tube voyez ça c'est ça c'est le sait le
discours un peu qui entraîne la
confusion parce que est lui même il fait
plus la différence entre l'efficacité
clinique et puis l'efficacité sur tel ou
tel variant il n'y a aucune étude qui a
montré un effet sur telle ou telle
variant en clinique
évidemment c'est impossible à faire
organiser un essai clinique c'est un
métier c'est pas celui de monsieur bré
chaud je le vois bien je le comprends
rien qu'à l'entendre je vois qu'il n'a
aucune expérience dans ce domaine mais
il a de l'expérience dans d'autres
domaines et je le respecte tout à fait
moi ma conclusion c'est sain
il y a dans notre pays aujourd'hui on
dirait deux clans 1 il ya le clan des
gens qui sont persuadés à l'avancé basé
essentiellement sur des préjugés ou sur
des options politiques il faut trouver
quelque chose pour arrêter la pandémie
il faut trouver une solution et à part
ça je le comprends très bien ce sont des
gens qui sont persuadés à l'avant ce qui
ont des convictions je dirais même plus
des préjugés et puis il ya le clan des
sceptiques est dans le camp des
sceptiques qui a essentiellement là il
ya évidemment quelques gentils vaccin
qui est qui ne raisonnent pas pas plus
que ceux qui sont absolument convaincus
que le vaccin va faire des miracles
woillet ces deux clans extrêmes ce que
j'explique qu'un dans mon livre c'est
une guerre de religion or c'est vraiment
le point fondamental
nous vivons en démocratie et dans toute
démocratie lorsqu'il y à un conflit une
discussion une discordance
il faut arriver à un compromis on ne
peut pas avancer sans faire de compromis
eh bien voyez mon point de vue qui est
simplement le point de vue des
scientifiques et médecins sceptique je
suis sceptique vis-à-vis de tout ça
comment comment on fait pour écouter les
sceptiques
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas droit à la
parole et je tiens à remercier votre
chaîne
et vous le présentateur qui avait fait
très bien votre travail de donner enfin
la parole à un sceptique qui n'est pas
un fou furieux qui est contrôlée bâclage
pour contre les vaccins j'écris un livre
là-dessus je vous remercie bien je vous
remercie de me remercier mais
malheureusement je vais devoir vous
couper la parole parce qu'on a déterminé
une dernière phrase il faut arriver à un
compromis pour avoir un compromis re
démocratie il faut que les gens s'écoute
et pas s'insultent toi et moi j'ai suivi
des insultes de la part de ce monsieur
mais c'est cette impression là moi je
lui je me julien je vous interromps
entre les deux allaient très bien que tu
as dit une phrase une phrase à christian
bréchot un mot oui je pense que je n'ai
absolument pas agresser monsieur doré le
tout ce qu'il m'a agressé 10 800 bisons
pas ce que c'est et en se sentant
agressé il revient avec son ton
méprisant le point n'est pas là je suis
d'accord avec lui sur le fait qu'il faut
trouver un compromis
je suis un scientifique et un même un
médecin j'ai fait beaucoup d'études
cliniques je n'accepte pas on peut avoir
une opinion divergente on ne peut pas
commencer à dire on voit bien qui n'a
aucune expérience en études cliniques
qui comprend rien et c'est ça ça ne fait
pas progresser le débat
contrairement à ce qui dit ce que je dis
ce que j'ai dit repose sur des gens qui
ont une expérience des études cliniques
ce sont des fêtes scientifique ce sont
des publications ce sont des réalités
scientifiques je suis tout à fait
d'accord pour qu'on débatte et qu'on ait
des sceptiques
je dis toujours fait mais par contre
qu'on débat d'une façon honnête c'est à
dire que reconnaissant que chacun
reconnaissant les qualités de chacun et
je pense que là dessus il faudra
s'arrêter mais le plus important n'est
pas là et j'arrête là dessus le plus
important c'est pas monsieur lors jury
des christian bréchot le plus important
c'est qu'on a des vaccins qui sont
efficaces et ça a été démontrée
scientifiquement sur des études
cliniques bien mené et qui montrent les
fesses de ses vaccins et il faut il faut
qu'on réussisse à avoir un dialogue
constructif
merci tous les quatre d'avoir participé
à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis
et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]